hey I'm Kristian harloff with fandango
movie clips with things to know before
you see Star Wars The Force awakens this
is the seventh film in the star wars
franchise but rather than wasting time
rehashing what you should already know
we should be talking about what you
don't know what everybody has a theory
about this is what I think we have
learned this is 30 years after Return of
the Jedi and it seems like there's some
version of the Empire that's back it's
called the first order Darth Vader the
Big Daddy from the original trilogy he's
gone but there's some dude now in a mast
in kylo Ren he looks like he's a fanboy
of Darth Vader and he's trying to follow
and the Dark Lord's footsteps who is
this guy and what is his agenda for me I
think that's Han Solo's kid yup I think
it's Hans kid I think it's Leia's kid
and I think ray is Luke Skywalker's kid
would that me and Luke is a deadbeat dad
maybe but the Jedi have been known to be
shady in the past and if that's not
enough to get you in full geek mode how
about two words han freakin solo
Harrison Ford has been on the record
saying that he wanted Han Solo be dead
kill off in Empire Strikes Back and
Return of the Jedi and it didn't seem
like he'd ever be back masport of JJ
Abrams JJ was able to get him back but
everything we have seen it looks like he
is having an absolute blast revisiting
playing the scoundrel again what's Hans
role and this is the one guy this was
the guy who doubted everything about the
force he didn't like hokey religions
well he's the one he's serving as a
guide now and a historian for our new
heroes Finn and Ray you're still not
geeking out fine two more words for you
Carrie Fisher yes Leia is back as well
so far we have seen brief footage of
Leia but all the shots have been
powerful but where is Luke that's the
million-dollar question we have seen
footage and pictures of Leia and Han but
Luke has been shrouded in mystery there
are crazy rumors out there that suggests
Luke could actually be evil some say he
might be on the run hiding out what
events happen from Return of the Jedi
until now that changed that lovable farm
boy into the recluse that's on the run
in the force awakens so that's what you
should be looking forward to when the
force awakens hits theaters in the
meantime go buy your tickets go to
Fandango get more tickets go see
get the force awakens I'm Kristian
harloff with fandango movie clips thank
you for watching us see you in the
theaters December eighteenth
you